it's being hailed as a vaccine for the
world
pharmaceuticals firm astrazeneca in
partnership with the university of
oxford says
interim trial results will be sent to
regulators immediately
in the hope their product is approved
for rollout before the end of the year
we've got a vaccine which is highly
effective
it prevents severe disease and
hospitalization
and intriguingly in the results although
the headline is 70 percent
protection and we do have a subgroup
who got a half dose as the first dose
and then a full dose as the second dose
where we saw 90 protection more data may
be needed to confirm the 90
subgroup results but cheaper to mass
produce
easier to distribute at more moderate
temperatures than its competitors
the british vaccine is good news for
poorer parts of the world
in time the astrazeneca oxford vaccine
could lead to an
end to the pandemic worldwide reaching
parts of the world the other vaccines on
offer
simply can't but on a much shorter time
scale it's already being projected by
the government here
that vaccine technology may lead to a
resumption of normal life
by easter i can therefore confront
the national restrictions in england
will end
on the 2nd of december addressing
parliament remotely while serving a
period of isolation himself
prime minister boris johnson outlined a
post-lockdown
plan for england a return to the
regional system of tiered restrictions
introduced in october
but strengthened this time to guard
against a further surge
first we must get through winter without
the virus spreading out of control
and squandering our hard-won gains
at exactly the time when the burden on
the nhs
is always greatest our winter plan
is designed to carry us safely to spring
so from december the second until april
shops will reopen
parts of the economy will be allowed to
breathe again
and the government has promised that
families can meet up over the christmas
period
there is more than cautious optimism
that an end to all of this
is insight jonah hull al jazeera london